I love playing darts I think you know
that we had a dart board grown up we
used to throw darts at each other
actually but would have do you do that
thing where you put your hand on the
hand on the dart board and you hope your
buddy misses it no we would turn out the
lights in the basement and everybody get
two darts and they could just whip him
whatever Direction you wanted to
that no it was a different time dude it
was a different time I
you wa you know listen we were it was it
was maybe we were unsupervised you know
that's more than
unsupervised it wasn't dude you could
have killed somebody yeah yeah mm but
did anybody any catastrophic injuries no
catastrophic injuries did you generally
miss each other except for once and
that's was the end of that game who got
hit uh and and where right in the
shoulder o you heard it wasn't the
normal cuz down in my basement okay my
dad had there's a pool table down there
when we were growing up there was a dart
board um and you guys are getting this
picture of this huge opulent we were
poor we had this crooked ass pool table
we had an old
dartboard um I I would tell you
something right now I actually bet you
this dude I bet you for
about well for at least 10 years eight
years EXC my mom was the only one
working
she worked at UMass ammer in the office
of internships I think maybe she made
$27,000 a year okay so I think that's
what we lived so when people are getting
this idea of this basement like this
huge man cave no no it was just you know
but my parents fallout shelter pretty
much yeah and my parents but my parents
were very they sacrificed a lot for us
it was amazing you know when we first
moved into that house we all had our own
separate room and they slept in the
living room really yep yep yep yep yep
um they sacrificed a lot but my dad in
the basement in the Northeast a lot of
it was very damp you know they had those
basements so for floods and water and uh
or or no no no uh uh they had those
basements I don't know why they built
the basements but they but they were
damp they were underground you know and
so he put plastic up over the cement
wall and then put wood over the plastic
so the all the walls were wood okay wood
boards so you would hear when you threw
the dart you missed you would hear GK
yeah yeah yeah yeah GK cuz it's stuck
into the wood yeah yeah yeah but every
now and then it would hit like a couch
or yeah but flesh made a different sound
dude and that was you heard like a you
heard GK and then a GK and then a Gunk
and then
a and then you heard turn the [__]
lights
on I thought someone goes what and he
said turn the light you hit me with that
d right in the [__] shoulder who was
it it was a buddy of mine yeah that's
pretty funny yeah it was not um yo dude
I used to hoe McCutchen and Amir Sayed
used to come over every Sunday we would
watch football and order pizza and we
were bet on the we'd make bets in the
pool and I you know I knew the curves of
the
table and like they definitely pay for
pizza every week dude Amir dude Amir
used to get [__] taken every week
Amir say my man I know you're not
listening to this and Howie dude Howie
was one my oldest friends ever but um
yeah dude uh uh uh we used to throw
darts at each other I love playing darts
I used to um hustle people darts but oh
yeah are you a good darts player oh yeah
I'm not usually a darts person but have
you been following the world darts
Championship uh the last couple weeks
absolutely not okay so the only reason I
following the world darts now I like
darts the world darts Championship you
heard that correctly and I know that in
like in the UK they sell out like yo
watching that [__] on TV with that crowd
is electric oh my God in a pub whatever
it is legit electric it is amazing the
English can drink and have fun with
anything and I [__] love it like
they're so funny to me I love that but
so there's a story that's kind of taken
the World by storm it's a there is a
16-year-old darts Phenom named Luke ller
and he has are you doing this with an
accent are you just sticking to what you
got no I'm just sticking to what I got
okay Luke ller
is legitimately flying like this kid has
come out of nowhere to beat some of the
world's best they've they've won this
championship before all these dudes are
like in you know in their 30s their 40s
they're veterans at this game this kid
is 16 years old he's blowing these
people out of the water like like in in
in a legit blowout fashion he just
played in the finals World darts
championship finals against the number
one player in the world uh whose name is
Luke humph um they actually played two
Lukes two Lukes two Lukes one humph one
ller um and humph actually played ller
in a pub when he was 12 four years ago
and said even then he was scary it's
just like this crazy Cinderella run that
has completely taken everybody this kid
Luke is being um like he's being asked
to get taken photos of with like
professional English footballers like
the whole whole world knows this kid's
name right now and every day he still
goes home his mom makes his bed and he
eats ham and cheese omelets like it for
me it's like the
craziest like out of nowhere like I just
like stories like this are really just
like he's like the [__] he's like the
the Ronaldo of darts or the Messi of
darts it's amazing